[Music]
and that's not it news submitted by
Asian Pablo Escobar ancestry.com
apologized and deleted a recent ad after
critics say a romanticized slavery Wow
what the [ __ ] do we have that yes we do
oh so the ad is called inseparable I
just pictured like a video of slaves
working happy and [ __ ] in the Riggin Oh
that'd be good
oh my god it's like they're breaking
into a musical it's like what have you
that's like I have you seen the [ __ ]
where people people who are like hey you
know everything's actually pretty great
and like everything's awesome
like you know digital slaves we're fed
really well like what okay people are
crazy I get it okay is it based off of
like a true story
well that photo was a mixed couple like
I mean I get it - I get it - but it's uh
just the way they shot it it's in the
way it's pretty coordinated it's really
weird you mean like Hallmark Channel II
yeah yeah it's a ferret that Hallmark
Channel vibe except that there was a
black person in it which threw me
because like we is this is a Hallmark
Channel thing is why is there a black
person in this I know because my mom
watches is there one black person in
that stuff yeah there's like never any
Latinos I guess it's incredible is it
what's this Christian soap opera you're
watching all right it's like Lori
Loughlin and in Lori Loughlin and wig
yes when they're talking to each other
we she's a lady from full health right
yeah yeah yeah the one who's like
indicted hmm yeah so for example like
just to give you guys an insight on how
people are reacting this one tweet says
nobody you know that no but
and then ancestry.com how can we overly
romanticize and create an irresponsible
a historical depiction of that
relationship between white men and black
women during the period of Chatel
slavery that completely disregards its
power dynamics and the trauma of sexual
exploitation oh [ __ ] unless it's based
off a true story that's what that's why
my mind went there because for me when
you think about most white and black
relations if it's a white male black
female it's just a lot of rape back then
but what people are saying so this other
tweet says while it's true that one in
four black folks who test their male
line through DNA end up finding a white
man it ain't because of no Dan slavery
love story so Thomas Jefferson didn't
love his slaves because that's not what
I heard crazy one out of four black
people in America have white DNA I mean
that's according to this tweet that's a
core of their population group that's a
lot your face that's great you know I
didn't know that why she's saying that
you can you can take it with a grain of
salt because it's just coming from a
person on Twitter like there's no like
like facts check yellow because the
Twitter person could have checked it on
Wikipedia the Twitter person could be me
just try and make an argument okay well
I hope they didn't just throw out
numbers okay so this other tweet says
what in the hell is this at ancestry why
do white people insist on romanticizing
my black female ancestors experiences
with white men during slavery they were
raped abused treated like animals beaten
and murdered by white men do they want
to see a commercial where somebody gets
raved and then like it's like
ancestry.com they would just rather not
see the commercial they felt so
compelled to tell a story they couldn't
take an actual couple I mean yeah you're
right it was so well I think if it was
like something that we all grew up
learning right like about a like like I
don't know like we learned about like
Harriet Tubman or whatever right like if
we knew about this like a interracial
couple during this time they had
forbidden love and they ran away and we
all knew about that story then this
would make sense a wholesome story John
think John Smith and Pocahontas one of
them
beautiful love stories of all time was
it no not the truth exactly dude there
is no there is no Great White Buffalo
there the [ __ ] story that is wait so
you telling me that she didn't have
talking animal friends there was no miko
there was no miko sorry joe colors of
the wind song happen though i love it
she really sang that song
I think she did Pocahontas - that's like
Peter Pan - I'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here
damiana Neverland what the hell is that
oh my god oh my that doesn't exist on my
leg like for me the current Star Wars
movies well you're talking about Finding
Neverland Peter Pan 3 that's the Michael
Jackson that's how the real Peter Pan
story would be
that's the real Peter Pan story to me
that's true that's returning afterwards
to Neverland but then think about hook
though even now it's like a middle-aged
man goes back to hang out the Lost Boys
it's like I don't know that sounds like
a case of molestation a little weird
yeah alright okay so after the crazy
amount of backlash ancestry has removed
the ad and this is a statement ancestry
has committed to telling important
stories from history this ad was
intended to represent one of those
stories we very much appreciate the
feedback we have received and apologize
for any offense that the ad may have
caused we are in the process of pulling
the ad from television and have removed
it from YouTube cut to the 23andme
corporate off as what's [ __ ] up dude
you know what would be so sick is if
companies like how cuz I've been
watching Game of Thrones - [ __ ] yeah
where they literally take the bad guys
and they put their heads on [ __ ]
pikes or the good guys oh [ __ ] that was
great why does it companies just say
like hey here's the pictures of all the
marketing team who did this [ __ ]
they're all [ __ ] fired
wouldn't that be tight then at least
you're like hey I know I know what
happened and you can't blame the big
company you're gonna blame those people
well yeah right
yeah I would if they did this where they
explain that story I think I'll be
totally different from this snippet 20
second thing and then also because of
the fact that the woman didn't even
speak she couldn't even say a single
word so people like it just it doesn't
rub them the wrong way to say nothing
well she didn't have any wine
doing like what were they he's like
talking about let's escape to the north
on the street like what cut yeah so
they're China's a mess they were limited
in budgeting
and that they had to run away but like
the whole thing too like we're in the
the girl she was just like like it
doesn't seem like she's also madly in
love with this man cause he's like
interrupting her heads like the whole
you know what sucks for that chick
though is that now she doesn't get like
all the sick ass ad revenue and [ __ ]
from that I love how that works but at
least she shouldn't have even taken that
hey when you're an actor you want to
take the job I don't care and I know
that a lot of my people would agree like
how you gonna read that script or that
treatment and think that's okay talk
sure yeah that was I can't I could kind
of see me being hurt we do because it's
based off of a true story right story
though Abigail that's what I'm saying is
they didn't explain it so no one knows
this true story but we all know like the
other you know like like we gonna do
like based on a true story or loved
loved one the one that they made a movie
out of recently the mandala is dying
with like that yeah I know shocking yeah
what is it it was another leg thank you
been the 50s right or something yeah cuz
it's not like they asked her to be a
minstrel or anything like you know they
asked her to probably just play the role
and it's based off of this character and
they shoulder the old photo and it's
like oh okay yeah that's dope that's
that's a piece of history yeah that's
true cuz they don't really tell you like
with these jobs or whatever they just
kind of give you a premise of what
they're gonna do but it's not until it's
cut up and then it goes back and forth
these marketing and then the head
honchos and then they go actually we
like this can we just edit it this way
now that tone is completely different
than what the script might have been -
it happened to that one model - and she
was a part of the photo shoot I forgot
which one it was but she did the dumb
that one yeah and then she didn't know
she was just hired to be a model she's
like oh sick I get six grand I always
hate that part how do you guys feel
about that the Dolce Gabanna one the
controversial one what you're asking me
but the Chinese girl that used [ __ ]
chopsticks to eat pizza yeah that was
tight what was that okay so what sounds
for me
but you're also I see you're asking me
to like if they were casting for
ancestry.com
it's not a forbidden love of like the
Chinese railroad worker with [ __ ] ash
all over his face I play that role hold
you true but I'm also like I also like
just doing fun stuff so I'd be down to
do anything
Wow I guess the closest thing would be
the bodyguard with Whitney Houston yeah
we're [ __ ] classic me Kevin Costner
save that woman use a [ __ ] great man
I've never less a reference what you're
talking about it's a great film when you
use him he saved that woman that's all
about Kevin Costner every time I hear
that song I'm like this is about Kevin
Costner
yeah a drag queen did queen of the night
at brunch last week that's ty and I
lived I know what you meant by that is a
song that Whitney performed in the movie
when she gets attacked yeah see thanks
to the slang video I know what I lived
means I mean what does it mean he was
like I was like whoo like that yeah yeah
had a good time I was in my prime
thank slang video and thanks slang
spreadsheet and the wig that's a
different video
excuse me great what was it again it's a
different video okay look up the video
where this professor that has a cheat
sheet for slang look up that video
[Music]